Play the song.
Hey, Prince, how are you?
I'm good, how are you?
I'm good. How's everything going on urine?
I'm playing catch-up. I've been away for a bit, so it's me playing catch-up.
Okay. Usually what happens in these service calls, I do have a deck where I present the KPIs, matrix, and what things are going on. But since for the last month, obviously for the month of March, and since Marcos has been recently assigned, so I did not.
prepare a dig because I did not have much data on it. But overall, I want to know about your experience and I will share what his experience is working with April. So that's what I want to discuss today. So how do you think how he's coping up?
Yu.
Mhm.
So far, the feedback I've gotten in terms of how he's doing is great. I'm hearing some good things. He's asking great questions. And I can see it for myself. He's asking good questions in the team channels when he's running into some issues. So that's the best thing that could happen is just him asking a lot of questions in these first few weeks.
of him integrating with the team just so that he can learn some things. But so far I have no complaints from time tracking, some of the metrics that we are observing and track, he's excelling in those. He's where I want for somebody in his role.
Rick.
with the time that he's been with us to be at. That's where I want him to be for sure. So I don't have any complaints so far.
Oh, great, great to hear that. And while I was discussing with him on a regular, just a five minute talk, so he told me, first of all, like he says that the team, entire team is super supportive and he is getting appropriate support from the TL and you. So he is really happy. He did mention though, like.
some issue came yesterday regarding a fish alert and you helped him out and you supported him and you talked with the client and the issue was resolved and that but he told me like I the major miss from his end was that he resolved the ticket before discussing.
And I said, yes, if you have to discuss anything in your team model or with present or TL or anyone you want to discuss, do not resolve the ticket. And he acknowledged that. So he's super happy working in this role. He says that he's learning a lot. So that's a good thing. And second thing, if he's making a miss, he's acknowledging it.
Yeah.
This is one of the biggest assets that I see because if some of the engineers I have worked, like even if they do mistakes, like they do not acknowledge it, and that's where the challenge comes in. But yes, if they know that they caught up with something and they need to improve on it, that's the best thing we know.
We have all learned from our mistakes and grown to these positions. So that's really great. Yeah.
Exactly.
Yes, definitely, and I...
And normally when we get it, essentially, I'm glad that he's shared that with you.
In those situations, there will always be negative surveys. There will be a negative survey, there will be a neutral survey, there will be positive surveys. I always say, just...
Don't hang out on either extreme.
When you get a positive survey, you are not the best in the world, right? When you get a negative survey, you are not the worst in the world either.
You have to balance the perspective of the client somewhere in the middle, because sometimes the issue is out of your control and sometimes the issue, yes, is with you. And if you can own up to what you made a mistake about, and that's something that you can acknowledge and correct, then that's where I want us to be and have that sort of a conversation where we
Hey.
We know what went wrong and then we can correct it and not have it happen again going forward. So I appreciate that he was able to share that with you, but it wasn't a big deal for me because I've dealt with his client for a while. And so I was able to help him in the moment to communicate with the client and have a conversation with the client on the phone as well.
Just to ensure that we cannot.
Sort of, you know, assure the client that what was done was not, because Marcos didn't do anything wrong from the remedial steps he took. He did the right thing. The only thing is the client did follow up, send a follow-up question, but when the client sent a follow-up question, the ticket had been set to complete.
at that point. And so the client felt that, oh, there are some things I wanted to get clarification on on what has been done that hasn't been forthcoming or haven't been sent to me before the ticket can be closed. So he's right in that the ticket was closed sooner, a little bit earlier. Had he held on to it for a few more minutes,
Yu.
Beyond that, he probably would have seen the clients follow up and been able to provide the answer because what the client was asking was something that was already done, except it was not in the email communication that was sent previously. So I communicated that to the client and the client is happy. Whereas we will have to eat.
Okay, great.
We will have to eat the survey for closing the ticket too early. I don't have a problem with that, with most times we will have to do that anyways. I cannot scrub it. But it's one of those moments we have to learn from and move on, but not beat up, beat ourselves up for it. So
Yeah, I agree.
I'm happy with what he's doing so fine. I think I've taken a look at some of the tickets he's worked on. It's mostly what I've been doing.
Paying attention to is is.
asking of questions when he doesn't know whether he's proactive in asking questions. Like just, it tells me a lot about somebody and how they ask questions. There's people who ask questions and say, I don't know how to do this. Can you help me?
But then there is also these people that have said, okay, I don't know how to do this. And this is what I've looked into and how to do it. And this is the challenge I've run into.
where there's been some effort put in place towards trying to resolve that issue yourself, and that's the mindset. And then people can move you along to finding that solution beyond that. Whereas if you are just right at the beginning saying, I don't know how to do it, and you've thrown your hands up, that's what I don't like.
But for him, I see the questions he asks. He's tried so many other things himself and different things and checked this documentation and checked this and the other. And then he's asking for further information beyond that. So I love that about his mindset. And I think that he'll be a good guy to work with and so far.
Great.
It is a pleasure to work with, so I don't have any complaints.
Yeah, great, great to hear that. And one thing I learned from you today, honestly, like you said, one specific thing, like if you're getting the best CSATs, you know, if you're getting good CSAT does not mean you are the best. And if you're getting low CSATs, that does not mean you're the worst.
It's just that the situation is there. So we need to make sure that we keep our head held high. And so I'll keep this learning for the rest of my life because, yeah, I was, I did not follow this, but definitely I'll follow this. Yeah. Good thing that you shared with me.
Yeah.
I'm glad. I'm glad. I'm glad I could share something useful to you. But yeah, I'm pretty happy with him. So let's, we'll convene, I guess, next week, next meeting. We'll have a bit more time spent with him. At least he would have spent more time with a few more of our clients and learnt a few more things up to that.
Next, next month.
Yu.
Point, so let's see how that goes, at least for this month.
Great, great to hear that and we'll meet you next month. Thank you so much for your time present.
Yeah.
Thank you for your time as well.
Have a great day.
You too, bye bye now.
Support.